good morning everybody
very happy to report this morning that
we are wrapping this effort up
although we still have work to do staff
will be fully engaged friday saturday
and sunday with
reconciling all of the records that we
have in place for all the boats that
were cast in clark county however
at this point uh what we have left are
the provisionals which after conferring
with staff we should
we expect no uh difficulties in getting
those rolled into the system
at some point late this afternoon we
have the cures
that the deadline is today at 5 pm
so at 5 pm we'll make a final sweep
through staff to see if there are any
cures that need to be handled will
be be sure to process those ballots
through
yesterday's count included an additional
123
ballots that came in for voters who had
cured their ballot
and i want to make an announcement to
the general public there's a lot of
misinformation that's going on from
groups
there is no communication coming
officially from this office
friday saturday or sunday there's no
communication that comes from in this
office when you
have an issue you communicate with the
election department so we are not
calling out with anything that
should be affiliated with our department
i want the general public to be aware of
that
and of course the canvas will be monday
1pm
and the commission chambers with that
will will open up for questions
if there are any
yes to say i think the last figure i
heard from provisional ballots was 60
000.
do you have a number or is it still 60
000 that
you believe will likely be entered into
the system i do not believe that they
will all be entered into the system they
are being processed to be verified as to
which
ones are eligible to be counted there
are still reports coming in
from the secretary of state that we have
to verify
we are not the only county who are
continuing to have votes
they had mail come in on tuesday there's
possibility that some of those folks may
be getting cures
we still have to be updated on those on
that information up until five o'clock
today but
all sixty thousand of those provisional
ballots i can tell you with a great deal
of certainty they will not all count
but that will be done today and those
numbers will be published this evening
a full count i won't until after the
canvas however that information is
available on the website
as far as the individual
oh i'm sorry you're talking about doping
cures that are in the system yeah how
many are left i misunderstood your
question my apologies that's 1585.
i do have that number my apologies
1 585 outstanding cures that are still
in the system that are eligible to
contact us by 5 pm
and again that number is 702-455-6552
and you don't have a number on the total
amount of provisional ballots correct
that will be counted no just the number
that are available to be counted
and that figure was still 60 that's
correct you were correct
yes uh mr gloria from the trump campaign
they are alleging that 80 000 ballots
that went out during the primaries came
back as
undeliverable but here in the general
election the same 80 000 ballots 7 000
came back counted as votes i was
wondering if this is anything that you
know about or if you'd like to respond
to that
i have no information on exactly what
they've identified as those ballots but
we'll certainly look into it if they
give it to us
unfortunately they don't give those
reports to us they're just going out to
the media
unfortunately there's a lot of
misinformation that's being put out
there but i have consistently
communicated to the general public and
the media that any
instance or regulatory that has been
pointed out to us has
we've come up with an answer to explain
exactly why those occurred
we will continue to do so
have you been asked for a recount yet by
any local candidate
they're not eligible to request a
recount until we've canvassed they'll
have three days after the canvas
in order to put that request in no i
have not
and then once they put that request in
uh you guys have five days
to start it and then is it another
additional five days to finish the
recount
that's correct
yes looking to the future um
how will this election affect elections
um in the future themselves just what
has happened and
just take you know what's your takeaway
the pluses and nicest
if you're both comfortable answering
that the reason we're good at what we do
in clark county and i stand on a very
solid foundation of registrars who have
come before me
we've set standards nationwide for what
we do we always work to make things
better
but all of us registrars are are not
policy makers
we're administrators so it'll depend on
what the legislature determines on what
to do after this election
we take orders from the state as far as
how we change any of our processes or
any laws that might change as to how we
administer and manage elections in clark
county and the state of nevada but
we'll always work to make things better
here will you get
to the legislature of what you've seen
for this election i'm sorry what uh
what uh what's your input that you'll
give to the legislature to make
to make things better uh that you see
well that's a little bit too early
uh it's probably inappropriate to make
those kind of statements now we'll
definitely
they listen to us as far as clerks and
registrars they're very good here
about hearing what our concerns are what
we had to deal with and what we think
might be
a good idea for improving things in the
future but it's a little premature at
this point to say anything
well there won't be any updates for the
week anymore any uh
another press conference like today
we'll be seeing you again here soon or
we'll see you tomorrow
10 am we've been on time every day
what updates will we can we expect
tomorrow one more
you've got one more unofficial report
that'll come out from clark county
after that it becomes official after i
canvass on monday
and then it goes to the secretary for
their activities
i just want to reiterate um yesterday
you had additional 123 dollars that came
in
not come in they were counted nothing
could come in anymore
the deadline was tuesday okay and then
1585
outstanding peered ballots and then 60
000 provisional ballots
that should roll in those that are
eligible to be counted that will go in
today
it's very clear in the in the law that
we have to finish by today 11 59.
the deadline for people who cure the
ballots for those 1500 or so
it's 5 pm today that's correct any
message to the public who may be
watching
before 5 to come and get it done
i think the public has heard a lot from
me in the past eight days
i've been pretty clear every single day
and what the deadlines are
my pio has done an excellent job of
keeping me
up to breast on what i should share with
the general public we've made it clear
when the deadline is every single day
we're
open we have the line open 702-455-6552
if you need to cure call that line and
we will help you
make it's the last day by sure
o'clock uh they can come to cure their
uh the balance but
another sixty thousand probation balance
is going to be starting
counted tonight or all the way until 16
or today will be today is the final day
to count we have to have
everything into the system that will be
looked at as our final unofficial
account and those sixty thousand
only those that are eligible to be
counted that will be rolled into the
system
we'll send it to the secretary i i can't
tell you when they plan to post but we
will certainly post by no later than
tomorrow
which we've done every day
thank you all have a great day we'll see
one more time